deutsche haben ja bekanntlich keinen
humor und das wollen wir heute mal
überprüfen denn im deutschen gibt es
tatsächlich relativ viele witze die sich
die leute erzählen und eine besondere
kategorie von witzen sind solche witze
wo man vielleicht eine frage stellt und
eine antwort hat und so ein kleines wort
spieler drin ist im englischen sagt man
dazu der jobs und die wollen wir heute
mal auf deutsch testen dazu eingeladen
haben wir ja los llanos du hast auch mit
witzen deutsch gelernt ja total gerne
weil selbst wenn der witz nicht
sonderlich witzig ist aber lieber in
müdes lächeln als nur langeweile und ich
liebte das hier das ist ein gutes
stichwort und damit janisch jetzt mal
seine besten jobs erzählen kann haben
wir dazu seinen sohn manuel eingeladen
hallo manuel hallo gabi willkommen
der deal ist jetzt janisch hat sich tage
lang vorbereitet er die besten witze aus
dem internet herausgesucht und manuel du
glaubst dass du nicht machen wirst ich
halte es für sehr unwahrscheinlich
gut das ist jetzt die herausforderung
gerne stummes manuel zum lachen bringen
mandl bist du bereit für das witze
feuerwerk deines vaters ich bin bereit
zwar würde ich sagen los geht's sommer
würde ich habe jetzt die besten biete
von denen angeblich schlechtesten liezen
wäre ausgesucht und ich werde dir
vorlesen ich bin bereit
bitte stell dir vor einen kugel auf
diese kugel sitzt ein bär und
schreibt etwas
und
wie nennen wir so was
kugelschreiber
wir haben ein talent
entdeckt ihr kennt ja alle den
kugelschreiber damit schreibt man ja ist
ein kugelschreiber und der witz hier
besteht darin dass man das ende
kugelschreiber mit einem bh
austauscht also dem tier
wie heißt der bruder vom 11
er ruiniert
ganz klassischer
sprachwitz 11 12 bis 12
willst du ein lied von bauch hören das
ist das
auch vom bau von der baustelle wir wären
ja
ich arbeiten kann
[Musik]
ich habe einen hipster und schienbein
getreten jetzt hab ich da was
passiert wenn man vorder und bier
gleichzeitig trinkt
man
wird
ja wer wortwitz ist eigentlich
selbsterklärend
cola bier
kollabieren
treffen sich zwei jeder einer tot
beide todt genau der mann den ich kannte
habe ich sonst
[Gelächter]
schreibe treffen sich zwei jäger beide
tot
dieser witz besteht heraus das treffen
zwei bedeutungen hat man kann sich
treffen wenn man wenn zwei personen sich
begegnen und hallo sagen treffen ist
jedoch auch das verb wenn man schießt
und man trifft das ziel das man hat also
die jäger können sich treffen und hallo
sagen aber hier haben sie sich
erschossen weil sie sich beide
gleichzeitig getroffen haben
übrigens wenn ihr gerne mit humor
deutschland dann können wir euch auch
unsere eps ziel länge empfehlen die hier
seht sieling ist eine app die ihr
kostenlos im app store und im google
place tor auf ihr handy herunterladen
könnt und damit könnt ihr quasi immer in
eurer tasche deutsch lernen es gibt
darin viele vokabeln und grammatik es
gibt geschichten in denen auch janisch
und ich dabei sind auch manuel und easy
sind dabei und das besondere an zieht
lang ist das ihr jedes wort und jeden
satz den er kennenlernt nicht nur hört
sondern auch selbst einsprechen könnt
ihr könnt eure stimme aufnehmen und dann
im anschluss eure stimme eure aussprache
vergleichen mit der original aussprache
und dadurch verbessert ihr schritt für
schritt eure aussprache und werdet auch
viel selbstbewusster im deutsch sprechen
treffen sich zwei wellen sagt die eine
oder ich glaube ich muss brechen
ich war nie meine nicht gesagt der witz
ist sehr witzig denn
wellen brechen also das was die welle
macht die baut sich so langsam auf und
irgendwann braucht bericht diese welle
und berechnen ist gleichzeitig das wort
für sich übergeben oder kotzen also wenn
das essen hier wieder rauskommt sagt man
auch brechen
ja
und was geht durch den wald und hat
einen fiesen schnupfen den kenne ich
moment
ich weiß es nicht mehr ein rotkäppchen
konnte ich doch nicht rotkäppchen
vielleicht kennt ihr
rotkäppchen das ist ein märchen ein
mädchen mit einer roten kappe und rotzen
ist das verb das man macht wenn man so
so schmid
das ist ein rotzen und hier wird trotz
käppchen
vereint was sagte überfahrene zu
dampfwalze
ich bin platt ja da bin ich aber parabel
nicht immer klar da bin ich aber platz
ist ein ausdruck der
des erstaunens wenn man überrascht sagt
boah da bin ich aber platz und jemand
der überfahren wurde ist natürlich
wortwörtlich platz
und was ist ein keks und der einbau ein
schattiges plätzchen
das besser als jeder dass mit diesen
kann nicht einer mal einer der einer der
wenigen witze die ich wirklich kann
auswendig und immer gerne erzählt
es ist am ehesten leute von ihnen witzig
finde ich genial was ist ein keks
im schatten ein schattiges plätzchen
großartig großartig
das ist ja eine lieblingswitze der
deutschen es gibt ein anderes wort für
keks und dass es plätzchen ich weiß gar
nicht genau was der unterschied ist keks
und plätzchen sind beides so cookie ist
einfach auf englisch und ein schattiges
platzieren ist gleichzeitig kann ein ort
sein ein schattiges plätzchen ist ein
schöner ort im schatten und das ist der
witz platzieren ist ein ort und
gleichzeitig ein keks
ich bin gerührt sagte detail
[Musik]
das ist ein beispiel von vielen von
diesen witzen die nur daraus bestehen
dass ein wort zwei bedeutung hat rühren
ist wörtlich wenn man einen teich macht
dann rührt man aber wenn man gerührt ist
ich bin gerührt dann ist man emotional
bewegt ich bin gerührt
von der teig ist
gerührt
diesen witz finde ich witzig und
gleichzeitig so traurig wie war die
stimmung in der ddr
hielt sich in grenzen
der ist ein bisschen bitter aber auch
dadurch ein bisschen lustig in der ddr
durfte man natürlich nicht ausreisen es
gab die grenze und wenn man sagt dass
sich etwas in grenzen hält dann ist es
nicht besonders stark ausgeprägt also in
diesem fall passt der ausdruck wörtlich
und auch idiomatisch
okay wie heißt ein spanier ohne auto
somit kam mit ganz sicher sinn
karriere spricht bein ist nämlich
dort sind kategorie irgendwie superstar
los
so jetzt kommt eine serie was machen
mathematiker im garten
[Musik]
rechnen irgendwas mit rechnen
den garten
rechnen sie ziehen wurzeln rätseln jetzt
kommt diese ganz tolle reihe mit mathe
witzen und das besteht immer daraus dass
es ein
mathematischen einen mathematischen
ausdruck gibt der gleichzeitig im echten
leben vorkommt eine wurzel ist ein
mathematischer ausdruck aber das ist
auch das ding unter einem baum
was machen mathematiker auf dem klo
phi phi phi
[Gelächter]
ist ja diese zahl pi ist das sozial kann
man es sagen ja ein wert wollen wir ja
da ist
was
macht ein mathematiker auf der ski piste
er rechnet mit brüchen
den fand ich gar nicht schlecht denn man
kann bruchrechnen also einbruch ist zum
beispiel ein viertel das ist ein bruch
und wenn man mit brüchen rechnet dann ja
rechnet man entweder wirklich mit diesen
mathematischen dingen aber mit etwas
rechnen ist auch etwas erwarten und
einbruch ist auch ganz wörtlich ich kann
mir den arm brechen
und wenn man mit brüchen rechnet dann
erwartet man unfälle die zu einem
knochenbruch führen
was sind die letzten worte eines
mathematikers
damit habe ich nicht gerechnet
was hat die afg gegen das internet
da sind zu viele links
was denken sich die gletscher zum
klimawandel
wir werden sie
so bei sehen er sehe
die gletscher die sind ja das ist ja
gefrorenes eis in den bergen und wenn
die schmelzen dann sind sie wasser und
ein wasser ist zum beispiel entweder
mehr oder im inland nennt man das see
ein see ist so was wie ein leck und wenn
man sagt wir werden zusehen dann heißt
das ja dass daraus wird ein see aus dem
bett aber gleichzeitig
wir werden sehen heißt auch ganz so was
wie wild sie mal gucken was passiert und
das ist ja irgendwie dass wir die leute
im moment mit tina wanderung gehen oder
hier nicht wir werden sehen wir werden
sehen und jetzt kommt ein lieblings von
mir was freut sich und stinkt
[Musik]
sagt mir ein geburtstagskind
sieht was gut sehr gut angefangen aber
es ist jedoch qualitativ schlechter weil
ich die besten
acht
das ist ein richtig schlechter wort wenn
es im deutschen jahre schlacht jetzt
schon wieder hinter der kamera weil da
wird so witzig ist so schlecht so
schlecht dass er witzig ist also
geburtstag wird das buch ersetzt durch
vor
und das heißt ja fords
geburtstagskind kind
was macht ein jäger wenn er eine chance
sieht
moment
sagte mir er stellt sich hin
ja das ist eigentlich nur die lustige
assoziation der jäger sieht eine
schlange panik ein schrecklicher moment
man weiß nicht was man mit dem tier
machen soll wird man angegriffen und
dann kommt die aufklärung die schlange
ist im deutschen ja auch das wort dafür
wenn man in einer schlange steht also
wenn menschen auf etwas warten und zwar
so viele menschen warten dass sich eine
schlange bildet und der jäger stellt
sich natürlich hinten in der schlange an
welche sprache spricht man in der sauna
schwitzen
und grippe
ja der ist total witzig das ist ein
richtig schöner deutschland wortwitz
schwitzen ist ja das was man macht wenn
einem heiß ist und schwyzerdütsch ist
das was die schweizer sprechen also das
schweizer deutsch nennt man in der
schweiz schweizerdeutsch und
ich kenne auch allen zara tweed aber den
verrate ich dir nicht
verraten
fahrrad und
verrat zwei völlig unterschiedliche
wörter aber theoretisch könnte man sie
gleich hören also eigentlich werden sie
auch unterschiedlich ausgesprochen aber
der witz ist dann dass sie ein bisschen
ähnlich sind verraten und fahrrad hören
sich eigentlich total unterschiedlich an
aber hier werden sie connected geht eine
schwangere frau zum bäcker und sagt ich
bekomme ein brot
[Gelächter]
den fand ich tatsächlich selber ein
bisschen witzig weil man sagt manchmal
wenn man etwas bestellt ich bekomme das
also man könnte sagen ich hätte gerne
ein brot man kann aber auch sagen ich
bekomme ein brot und wenn man schwanger
ist dann bekommt man ein kind also beim
benutzt das gleiche wort das gleiche
werk man sagt zum beispiel wir bekommen
ein kind wir bekommen ein mädchen wir
bekommen einen jungen und dann geht die
schwangere frau zum der karren sagt ich
bekomme ein
einbruch bei adidas was schickt die
polizei
drei streifen natürlich
ja total witziger sitzt eine streife ist
auch ein
umgangssprachliche sword für einen für
eine polizeiauto oder führen so eine
gruppe also eine streife sind zum
beispiel zwei polizisten die zusammen
patroullieren ist eine streife und war
die das gibt es natürlich drei streifen
auf dem schuh
und fragt der polizist haben die
restalkohol
alles ausgebucht
restalkohol ist das wort dafür wenn man
nach vielen stunden noch alkohol im blut
hat also tatsächlich wird manchmal auch
in deutschland auf der straße
kontrolliert auch zum beispiel sonntags
morgens wird manchmal kontrolliert es
kann ja sein dass jemand bis 3 uhr
nachts feiern war und dann hat er nur
drei stunden geschlafen und morgens hat
er immer noch restalkohol im blut und
darf eigentlich nicht auto fahren und
der witz hier ist der polizist fragt
haben sie noch restalkohol und der
fahrer versteht das wörtlich ob er noch
reste vom alkohol hat zum trinken und
sagt nein alles ausgetrunken
der verbrecher sitzt weil er gestanden
hätten
wir interessieren uns alle für die
sprache und diesen angelehnt an
die art wie wir die sprache behandelt
der ist sprachlich ganz interessant denn
sitzen ist natürlich ein wort ganz
wörtlich ich sitze hier am tisch aber
sitzen ist auch ein synonym dafür dass
man im gefängnis ist man sitzt ein oder
man sitzt in der zelle das dann versteht
man dass jemand im gefängnis sitzt und
stehen ist hier das wort wenn man steht
also wenn man nicht sitzt und gestanden
etwas gestehen ist das wort wenn man
zugibt ein verbrechen begangen zu haben
ich habe gestanden dass ich ja nur
geklaut habe diese partitur von den
beiden werben gestanden und gestanden
sind identisch aber es sind zwei
unterschiedliche werben stehen und die
stirn und das ist der witz
ja dieser hass
unendlich
entschuldigen sie wissen sie wie diese
brücke heißt kennedy brücke war umso
besser und wie heiß sie nun
ja das sind diese total witzigen
wortwitze wo man dann noch wörter aus
einer anderen sprache mitmischt kenne
die
stadt für kennedy steht das dann statt
für die person kennedy steht das 4 ich
kenne die brücke
forscher haben letztens herausgefunden
sind dann aber direkt wieder
reingegangen
den fand ich gar nicht so schlecht
herausfinden dass das bedeutet dass man
den ausgang gesucht und dann dorthin
findet also wenn man es ganz wörtlich
versteht heißt
herausfinden ich bin ich habe aus dem
labyrinth heraus gefunden zum beispiel
herausfinden kann aber auch sein dass
man etwas neues erfährt also forscher
die forschen ja und wenn die etwas neues
entdecken dann kann man auch dieses verb
herausfinden benutzen und der witz ist
dass man dir denkst forscher haben etwas
herausgefunden also sie haben etwas
neues entdeckt aber hier ist es wörtlich
gemeint sie haben aus dem gebäude heraus
gefunden dann sind sie da rein gegangen
sagt der pessimist schlimmer geht gar
nicht sagt er optimistisch
ja der witz ist dass der optimist sagt
sie ja doch schlimmer kommt es mit
sicherheit ein pessimist sagte schlimmer
kann es gar nicht mehr
mit
doch ist ja ein besonderes wort am
deutschen dass es eigentlich damit
widerspricht man jemanden du sagst ich
kann das nicht und ich sage doch dann
heißt das eigentlich du kannst das schon
und ja hier widersprechen sich dann der
pessimist der sagt das geht nicht
schlimmer der optimist ist natürlich
optimistisch und sagt doch das geht noch
schlimmer
und die musste ich zweimal lesen und hin
zu begreifen sagt der walfisch zum
thunfisch was wollen wir thunfisch sagte
thunfisch du hast die wahl fisch
jetzt verstehe ich den so wörtlich
sagt die eine kerze zu anderen du isst
wasser eigentlich gefährlich sagt die
andere
davon kannst du ausgehen
klasse klassiker der witz hier ist dass
es diese doppeldeutigkeit gibt ausgehen
von etwas ausgehen heisst damit kann man
rechnen oder das kann man erwarten wenn
die kerze also sagt davon kannst du
ausgehen dann heißt das ja du kannst
erwarten dass wasser gefährlich ist
ausgehen ist aber auch wörtlich was die
kerze macht wenn die flamme aus
gibt also das feuer ist nicht mehr da
dann geht die kerze aus man kann auch
sagen das licht geht aus also
ja du also die das ist einfach die
doppeldeutigkeit du kannst davon
ausgehen dass wasser gefährlich ist denn
du kannst davon ausgehen wörtlich ich
würde sagen wir machen jetzt schluss ich
hätte aber noch einmal so richtig nett
weil viele okay das war unser großes
germany jobs spezial manuel doris mehr
gelacht als du angekündigt hat ist
das ist doch schön das ist doch ein
erfolg für dieses projekt ich bin ganz
gespannt was er dazu sagt habt ihr denn
die witze verstanden wie fandet ihr die
witze würdet ihr sagen die deutschen
machen gute witze am guten humor oder
sagte er nicht das waren wirklich sehr
schlechte deutsche jobs ein habe ich
noch wie viele deutsche braucht man noch
eine glühbirne zu wechseln
2 1 soll sie ziert sind und keine humor
sehr gut
schreibt uns mal eure kommentare wie ihr
eure witze gefunden habt und wenn wir
wollen dass sie habe ich noch mehr jobs
hier auf diesem kanal erzählt schreibt
uns einen kommentar und ansonsten
wünschen wir euch vor weihnachten und
wir machen aber weihnachten eine kleine
pause und sehen uns hier auf den kanal
am zweiten januar wieder
klar ist bald
wusste
meyer
ja ja ja ja ja